[Music]
thank you
[Music]
right where have you been I've turned
avoiding talking to other people in some
Olympic sports
that I could sleep in their bathtubs
[Music]
bye bye
they terrify me so creepy
I feel like they sleep upside down do
they wear matching balls every day that
little weirdo makes the best one really
I've ever had three honeymooned in sea
Islands
[Music]
seriously yeah did you eat at Dominics
yeah technically a worse less important
apartment
I haven't really gotten to talk to Frank
very much Frank doesn't have to talk to
you
oh I'm sorry I didn't you have no idea
how extraordinary he is or what he can
do you're lucky to even know who he is
let alone be standing in his house funny
I'm just excited I'm sorry
I was just excited
oh
guys yeah
[Music]
the round everyone
now usually we don't have the
opportunity to welcome couples in our
home but on this occasion we just
couldn't wait to celebrate our newest
residence
bill
violet
I am so happy for you that you get to
learn from my husband
and join this mission
and become a part of this family
Frank has built something
truly special
what he's created out here it's
it's a different way
a better way
and we only have each other why are we
here
foreign
we shouldn't be here
no no
Margaret and Ted are going through a
difficult time
Margaret's question is right it is the
good question to ask
why the hell are we here
why when this landscape can seem so
Barren so hard so dusty so
worthless
why not run
I want to go back to safety status quo
word safe where we should be no I choose
we choose to stand our ground
right to look harder to dig deeper
to mine that pure
unbridled
potential
that gem
of Limitless and unimaginable
value
it's too easy to get distracted by what
seems
much more difficult braver I would say
to search for what could be
Dean
what is the enemy of progress chaos yes
the word
chaos
merciless foe at chaos
energy unfocused Innovation hindered
hope strangled greatness disguised I see
greatness in each one of you I know
exactly who you are
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
that's right
I look around I see another reason why
I'm here
once unfamiliar faces strangers one and
all now
one Brave family men like Dr Collins one
of our first who built this community
with me thank you Dr Collins for your
vision
and adventurers like Bill
our newest Intrepid Explorer this Brave
Young Robinson Caruso is choosing to
join us on
this adventure Bill thank you for being
our partner in this
and thank you violet
for being his partner in this he could
not do this without you
all of you wives
We Men We ask a lot
we ask for strength shoulder to cry on
food at home a house cleaned and
discretion Above All Else and that
very difficult
you are my rock
I would not be here without you
thank you
[Music]
you're all dismissed
[Laughter]
Jack
Jack Margaret they're hiding me in here
oh give us a second Alice she'll be fine
I'm not fine
nothing is fine she just needs to sleep
I don't sleep
I have bad dreams
foreign